personne ne mérite d'être mutilés à vie
par une arme à un policier
[Musique]
il est 17h ce 27 novembre 2007 et la
manifestation des lycéens et étudiants
touche à sa fin les esprits s'échauffent
entre les forces de l'ordre les
manifestants
c'est à ce moment là qu'un lycéen tombe
à terre ce qui est intéressant c'est une
certain à ce moment là ni chez les
journalistes ni dans la famille qu'est
les larmes qui l'atteint chif
en novembre 2007 le lanceur de balles de
défense le lbd40 est expérimental alors
cette arme était le responsable
en tout cas deux tirs ont été effectués
avec ce lanceur de balles de défense
une arme plus précise que le flash-ball
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on décide de ne
pas faire confiance à la police des
polices décide de mener une enquête
indépendante autonome en criant un
groupe de travail avec tout un tas de
proche de ma famille qui vont
spontanément dire nous a enquêté sur
cette affaire on lâchera jamais la faire
face à ce policier face à sa hiérarchie
donc déjà pour commencer on va aller au
tribunal administratif
on va attaquer l'état on va attaquer la
hiérarchie policière et ensuite on ira
plus loin s'il le faut la la commission
européenne des droits de l'homme
[Musique]
le fait que l'italie était condamné pour
usage de cette arme
depuis elle d'autres condamnations qui
ont eu lieu deux condamnations
et ça n'a absolument pas empêché
l'explosion de l'usagé du lanceur de
balles de défense
[Musique]
les lanceurs de balles de défense
utilisé plus que jamais c'est à dire que
dans les trois premiers en moins
mouvementée chez les jeunes à la fin de
l'année 2018 au début de l'année 2010
mais on a eu plus de dire que les vingt
dernières années par des flash ball et
les lance heures en vol qantas
[Musique]